look at these people so everyone at this
company clinically depressed everyone
here is doing by a spread because snack
at any moment as our tools in this
situation yes thank you for self as
tools
you guys are tools the well-being of our
employees is an all-time low it's real
children once happy innocent children
and now look at them
thank you for yourself as tools they're
all just trying to fill the void the
void you know the emptiness that exists
inside all of us were you getting all
that cake from you guys our tools
question why do you think it's ok to
come into work with your shirt untucked
because life is meaningless and nothing
we do matters thank you for yourself as
tool hey Matt I thought you were dead
that turns out you're just sleeping on
the toilet Richard we all want to kill
ourselves you're fired
congratulations the only way to beat the
system is to turn the system against
itself Oh
PowerPoint proficient I'm more than
proficient I
especially still in my resume
no no there's no God muck there is a ton
of money to be made in his name I feel
like we're experiencing something really
special
got'em
[Music]